- [Voiceover] In the last
video on step response,
we set up the differential equation
that describes our
circuit, and we found that
it was a non-homogeneous equation,
and now we're gonna follow through
on the strategy of solving it with a
forced response plus a natural response.
So here's two copies of our circuit,
and we're gonna, on the top one here,
we're gonna solve for
the natural response,
and on the bottom one, we'll use that one
for the forced response.
Alright, let's go to work on the natural.
Now, to do a natural response,
what we do is we set
the initial conditions
to whatever they were
for the original circuit,
so that involves some q
and a v zero, a v naught on the capacitor.
So let's just draw in
quick, let's draw in our q.
There's some q here, that'll
be a plus or minus v naught
on the capacitor.
Now the other thing we
do, is for the inputs,
we set the inputs to zero
to do the natural response.
And how you do that,
our input here is a voltage source,
and we're gonna suppress
the voltage source,
that's how we do it with super position.
When you suppress a voltage source,
what you do is you set
the voltage to zero.
And that means that's the same as creating
a short circuit for this.
So, for the natural response
we're gonna take out
our voltage source
and replace it with a
short circuit, like this.
So, this circuit now is identical
to the circuit that we used
for the natural response.
So, if you haven't seen that video
on how to solve for the natural response,
this would be a good
time to go look at that.
What I'm gonna do now is just write down
the answer from that, this
will be plus or minus,
we'll call this v natural,
and that equals
some k natural
times e to the minus t
over
r c.
This is the natural
response of an r c circuit,
so I'll put a square around
that so we can remember it.
And I've left the constant in here,
and we'll work out what this
constant is a little bit later.
Okay, so now let's move on
and do the forced
response for this circuit.
And for the forced response,
we remember the initial
conditions are set to zero.
So that means that q equals zero here,
and that means that
initial v
is zero.
I'll just write in zero.
So that's what it means to set
the initial conditions to zero.
And the inputs
are equal to,
we use to inputs this time,
the input is equal to v s.
And in particular, the
input is equal to v s,
we're gonna solve the forced response
after time is equal to
zero, so that means that
the input is
v s,
capital v s.
And as a reminder, what
we're trying to solve here
is the differential equation
from the previous screen,
and that is
c
times d v
d t,
I'll put a forced in here,
plus one over r,
times v forced
equals one over r
times v
s,
and I can plug in capital v s here
because we're trying to solve this
for this initial condition.
So this is our differential equation
for the forced response,
and we're gonna take a strategy here
that's like we did with
the natural response,
is we're gonna guess at an answer for v f,
and then plug it into this
differential equation,
this non-homogeneous
and we're gonna see if it works.
And a good guess here
is to guess something
that looks like the input.
So a good guess is gonna be some function
that looks like v s.
And v s looks like what?
V s looks like, over here,
v s looks like a constant.
So we're gonna make a guess here that
the forced response
looks like some constant,
we'll call that k f.
The way we test our guess is
to plug it back into here.
Plug it back into the
differential equation.
So I'm gonna do that, alright so we get
c times
the derivative of k f,
with respect to time,
plus one over r,
k sub f,
equals
one over r
times v s.
Alright, now here's the interesting
thing that happens next.
What's the derivative of a
constant with respect to time?
That's
That goes to zero.
So this first leading term here
of our differential equation
goes to zero,
and now I'm left with
k f times one over r
equals v s times one over r.
So that makes k f equal to v s.
So I'll tuck this in here,
our forced response,
v f
equals
v s.
So now I have our
natural response right here,
and in this square we
have our forced response,
the forced response is
just a constant v s.
So now we're ready to come
up with our total response,
and we'll call that v capital t,
the total response is equal
to the natural response
plus
the forced response.
So now we're using our
principal of super position.
Okay, v t
equals
k
some constant times e
to the minus t
over r c.
And let's add the forced response,
and the forced response is right here,
it's v s,
and we're getting close,
the only thing we have left is
to figure out this value now,
we have to figure out the gain factor
in front of the exponential
term of the natural response.
Now the way we go after that,
is we would know this
if we knew what v s is,
and we do, it's called v s.
If we knew v t at some time,
we could plug in two values here.
We could plug in a v t and a t,
and one of the most
convenient times to know this,
if we set t equal to zero,
and we know that the total
at time equals zero is what?
It's basically, let me roll
it up here a little bit,
let's go backwards a little bit.
Let me go back here and
use this diagram again,
this was the forced response,
so we're not gonna use that right now.
We're gonna use, this
is now the total circuit
all assembled together,
and we have to figure out
what is the actual initial charge on here,
and if we recall, the
initial charge on here
was v
naught,
it was this value here,
just before time equals zero,
this was the value of the
voltage on that capacitor.
So I can fill that in here, v naught.
Alright, let's go back
to our total solution
and plug in these two values,
time is zero and v t equals v naught.
So that looks like
v naught
equals
natural constant times e to the minus zero
over r c
plus v s.
And let's solve for k n
k n
equals,
this term is e to the zero
is one,
so this term goes to one,
that says that it's k n plus v s,
is this side,
and I can write down here
v naught
minus
v s.
So now I've solved for k,
and we can finish our total response,
we can say the total
response is v t equals
k sub n,
which is v naught minus v s,
e to the minus t
over r c
and
plus v s.
And that is the total response
of our circuit,
and we saw that in two steps,
first we did the natural
and then we did the forced
and we added them together and
worked out the last constant,
whatever the constant was,
and there's our answer.
So in the next video we'll
do an explicit example
with values for r and c in the step
and we'll see what it actually looks like.